[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Marietta Slomka guten
Abend seit Tagen schon wütet
exos-präsident Donald Trump wie ein
Berserker und sendet auf seiner Social
Media Plattform wilde Botschaften und
das quasi im Sekundentakt Anlässe findet
der reichlich angefangen mit dem
Untersuchungsausschuss der Ihnen als
Hauptverantwortlichen für den
Putschversuch am 6 Januar 21 benennt
dann wären dann noch etliche
Gerichtsverfahren mit Anklagen die von
Steuerbetrug bis Entwendung von
Geheimdokumenten reichen doch für ihn
das Schlimmste dürfte sein dass heute
seine Steuerunterlagen veröffentlicht
wurden seit dem Watergate-Skandal in den
70er Jahren ist das eigentlich üblich
für Präsidentschaftskandidaten nur Trump
weigerte sich jetzt weiß man auch warum
entweder hat der Mann sich künstlich Arm
gerechnet oder er war nie ein
erfolgreicher superunternehmer aus
Washington
Winterwetter Kinderbücher und die
neuesten tiktok Trends beim
erzkonservativen Sender Fox News geht es
heute um so ziemlich alles nur nicht um
Trumps Steuern viele Republikaner stehen
noch immer zu ihrem Idol und halten die
Veröffentlichung der Dokumente für
falsch
ich teile die Kritik der Republikaner
klar irgendwann wären die Unterlagen eh
an die Öffentlichkeit gelangt aber es
fühlt sich so an als sei das Ganze eine
Rachefeldzug der Demokraten solange sie
noch die Mehrheit im Repräsentantenhaus
haben und Republikaner denken sich nun
okay wie du mir so ich dir es wird der
Tag kommen an dem sensibler Dokumente
eines Demokraten veröffentlicht werden
und dann können Republikaner sagen ihr
habt schließlich damit angefangen
in diesen Kisten sind sie aufbewahrt
Trumps Steuerunterlagen um deren
Veröffentlichung seit Jahren hart
gekämpft wurde nun sind sie also publik
es wird deutlich dass der damals
mächtigste Mann der Welt der sich gerne
als Genie feiert und fast täglich mit
seinem Reichtum prahlt nicht die Steuern
gezahlt hat die jeder andere normale
Mensch in diesem Land gezahlt hätte
in einem Jahr zahlte er gar nichts er
machte große Abzüge und Kredite geltend
nutzte jedes Schlupfloch das Erfinden
konnte
aus den Dokumenten ist also ersichtlich
das Trump jahrelang kaum oder keine
Steuern abgeführt hat vor allem deshalb
weil angeblich die Verluste seiner
Unternehmen so hoch gewesen sein dass er
kaum Gewinner Einfuhr Trump äußerte sich
bisher nur schriftlich
die Demokraten hätten das nie machen
sollen und der Oberste Gerichtshof hätte
es nicht zulassen sollen es wird zu
schrecklichen Dingen führen für viele
Menschen die große Spaltung Amerikas
wird nun noch viel schlimmer werden die
radikalen Linken Demokraten benutzen
alles als Waffe
außerdem bemerkenswert die meisten
Steuererklärungen wurden bei der
amerikanischen Finanzbehörde iOS nicht
überprüft was eigentlich bei jedem
US-Präsidenten üblich ist der Verdacht
steht im Raum dass der damalige Chef des
IRS der als Trump nahe gilt hierbei eine
Rolle spielen könnte einer seiner
Vorgänger meldet sich heute zu Wort
ich beobachte die Vorgänge mit großer
Sorge es wundert mich dass der irs-chef
der damals im Amt war nicht klar gesagt
hat wir müssen uns die Steuererklärungen
anschauen und nach Recht und Gesetz
handeln also ich denke die Finanzbehörde
hat einiges zu erklären
ob Trumps steuerangaben ihm juristisch
gefährlich werden könnten ist noch nicht
klar in jedem Fall werden sie seinen
politischen Gegnern in die Hände spielen
wie der Rest der zahlreichen Vorwürfe
die in den letzten Monaten gegen Trump
erhoben wurden
für Vladimir Putin war Donald Trump ein
Glücksfall bei dessen Wahl 2016 hatten
die Russen ja sogar ihre Finger mit ins
Spiel zumindest gab es im Wahlkampf
Kontakte und Unterstützung und auch auf
Trumps Wiederwahl hatte Putin wohl
gehofft auf einen US-Präsidenten der die
NATO schwächt und der Ukraine nicht
hilft es kam bekanntlich anders sein
Krieg hat Putin dann trotzdem gestartet
und damit der Welt vor Augen geführt was
sie eigentlich schon lange hätte wissen
können dass dieser russische Herrscher
davon träumt die alte Sowjetunion wieder
auferstehen zu lassen auf die er sich in
seinen Reden immer wieder bezieht und
für deren Glorifizierung er seit vielen
Jahren sorgt selbst der Massenmörder
Stalin taucht wieder als Nationalheld
Nina lieber geil blickt zurück auf diese
Sowjetunion die heute vor 100 Jahren
gegründet wurde
sich Putin gerne feiern lassen von den
Herrschern ehemaliger Sowjetrepubliken
100 Jahre nach Gründung der Sowjetunion
wollte der russische Präsident
eigentlich auftrumpfen als siegreicher
mächtiger Anführer denn dass das
Großreich 1 zerfallen ist aus Putins
sich dein Fehler der korrigiert werden
muss wie er seit fast 20 Jahren betont
es sollte anerkannt werden dass der
Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion die größte
geopolitische Katastrophe des 20
Jahrhunderts war
für mich war das eine Tragödie so wie
für die meisten Menschen in unserem Land
was bedeutet denn der Zerfall der
Sowjetunion das war der Zerfall des
historischen Russlands das damals als
Sowjetunion bezeichnet wurde wir haben
40% unseres Territoriums verloren
doch Putins groß macht Fantasien sind
nicht aufgegangen der Einmarsch in die
Ukraine ist längst nicht zu erfolgreich
wie geplant
trügerisches daher der Glanz dieser
Ausstellung mitten in Moskau über die
glorreichen Errungenschaften der
sowjet-republiken Galina michalowbar ist
russische
Oppositionspolitikerin und setzt sich
für Bürgerrechte ein die sie heute wie
damals in Gefahr sieht
wir sehen alte Muster wieder wir haben
wieder einen Polizeistaat die
staatssicherheitsorgane lenken alles der
einzige Unterschied zur Sowjetunion ist
das ist jetzt statt Partei funktionieren
Oligarchen gibt
um Völkerfreundschaft friedliches
Miteinander geeint im Kommunismus darum
sei es nie gegangen
strohend
die Sowjetunion war schon von Lenin auf
widersprüchlichen Prinzipien gegründet
versprochen wurde das Recht aller Völker
auf Selbstbestimmung aber in
Wirklichkeit befand sich das Land im
eisernen Griff der Kommunistischen
Partei und des KGB es war eine
Gewaltherrschaft
gegründet nach einem blutigen
Bürgerkrieg am 30 dezember 1922 bleibt
die Sowjetunion ein Staat der auf Gewalt
setzt der Diktator Josef Stalin ließ
politische Gegner verfolgen und ermorden
die Zwangskollektivierung der
Landwirtschaft brachte Millionen
Menschen den Hungertod viele davon
Ukraine
aber der Sieg über die Deutschen im
Großen Vaterländischen Krieg wie die
Russen ihn nennen schweißte die Sowjets
zusammen
die dunklen Kapitel wurden nie
aufgearbeitet zu Stalins Geburtstag
legen Kommunisten auch in diesem Jahr am
Kreml Blumen nieder 60 Prozent aller
Russen sehen den Zerfall der Sowjetunion
negativ
Putins Macht streben bedroht die
Meinungsvielfalt intellektuelle die
Kritik am Ukraine Einmarsch äußern
verlassen aus Angst das Land darunter
auch Historiker andre zudorf
die Epoche der Sowjetunion wird als
friedlich und ruhig bewertet die
Menschen denken an ihre Großeltern die
damals jung waren verliebt
familiengründeten eine rosarote
Vorstellung der Vergangenheit
Putin treibt die gefährliche Sowjet
Nostalgie auf die Spitze doch die
Invasionen die Ukraine hat auch die
Länder erschreckt mit denen Russland
einst in der Sowjetunion verbunden war
das Verhältnis der Sowjetunion zur
Volksrepublik China war nicht gut obwohl
man doch Brüder am Geiste war das hat
sich längst geändert Moskau sucht ein
enges Bündnis mit Peking wobei Putin
befürchten muss dass er dann nur der
Juniorpartner ist Hannah heute gab es da
eine Videokonferenz zwischen den beiden
Präsidenten ja und bei dem Gespräch
machte der Kreml Chef deutlich dass er
die militärische Zusammenarbeit der
beiden Länder stärken will zudem Putin
den chinesischen Präsidenten schied zu
einem Staatsbesuch im Frühling nach
Moskau ein sie erklärte laut dem
chinesischen staatsender CCTV das China
bereits sei die strategische
Zusammenarbeit mit Russland auszubauen
zum Ukraine Krieg werde er weiterhin
eine objektive und unparteiische Haltung
einnehmen
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg hat die
Bündnisstaaten zu weiteren
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine
aufgerufen Putin müsse überzeugt werden
dass er sein Ziel nicht erreicht dann
könne es eine friedliche
Verhandlungslösung geben sagte er
gegenüber der Deutschen Presseagentur
auch heute gab es wieder Drohnenangriffe
in der Ukraine dabei war vor allem Kiew
das Ziel obwohl laut Behörden alle
Drohnen abgeschossen werden konnten
sorgten ihre Trümmerteile für Zerstörung
nach Italien führen nun auch weitere
europäische Länder eine
corona-testpflicht für Reisende aus
China ein nämlich Frankreich
Großbritannien und Spanien hintergrund
ist die massive Infektionswelle in der
Volksrepublik
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
erklärte heute dagegen dass er dies
nicht für notwendig hält erforderte
stattdessen ein europaweites Varianten
Monitoring an den Flughäfen der EU so
könne im Falle des Auftretens von
besorgniserregenden Varianten sofort
gehandelt werden
die frühere Regierungschefin Myanmars
AUNS sanssoucci ist zu sieben weiteren
Jahren haftverurteilt worden ein von der
Militär herunter kontrolliertes Gericht
sprach die 77-Jährige wegen angeblicher
Korruption schuldig es ist das letzte
Urteil gegen die
Friedensnobelpreisträgerin nach einer
ganzen Reihe von Verfahren ihre
Gesamtstrafe soll sich damit auf 33
Jahre belaufen die EU und die USA
kritisierten die Verurteilung scharf
die steigenden Energiekosten und die
rekordinflation in diesem Jahr haben
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher
finanziell deutlich zu spüren bekommen
hinzu kam Rezessionsangst in der
Wirtschaft und auch an der Börse
Ernüchterung Frank Bethmann wagen wir
mal einen Blick nach vorne besteht
Hoffnung dass 2023 trotz der schwierigen
Umstände besser wird normalerweise sind
hier an der Börse ja die Optimisten zu
Hause doch auch die können nicht leugnen
dass 2023 finanziell ein schwieriges
Jahr wird vor allem wegen der anhalten
steigenden Preise viele spricht dafür
dass die meisten Menschen im nächsten
Jahr real also nach Abzug der
Inflationsrate noch etwas weniger im
Portemonnaie haben werden als 20 22 das
RWE Leibniz-Institut für
Wirtschaftsforschung beispielsweise
prognostiziert dass die realen im
kommenden Jahr noch einmal um 1,7 %
sinken werden die Löhne steigen also
nicht so schnell wie die Inflation das
mit der Teuerung links noch nicht
Schluss sei andere warnt auch der Chef
des rewe-konzerns Lionel Suk er geht
davon aus dass die Lebensmittelpreise
2023 weiter steigen werden um 5%,
vielleicht auch etwas mehr wie in einem
Interview sagte und wie könnte das
Börsenjahr 2023 Aussehen ja vielleicht
ist es etwas Optimismus ja gar nicht so
verkehrt zum einen sind solche Verluste
wie in diesem Jahr der Dax hat 12%
eingebüßt er die Ausnahme zum anderen
gibt es so ein ungeschriebenes Gesetz
dass die Kapitalmärkte der Konjunktur im
Durchschnitt ein halbes Jahr
vorauslaufen stimmen also die Annahmen
dass der wirtschaftliche Tiefpunkt zur
Mitte des kommenden Jahres erreicht wird
dürfte es mit den Aktien spätestens in
der zweiten Jahreshälfte wieder aufwärts
gehen doch ehrlicherweise muss man
hinterherschieben sicher vorhersagen
kann das heute keiner wir haben es in
diesem Jahr erlebt die größten Risiken
sind immer die die niemand auf der
Rechnung hat aber eigentlich kann es ja
nur besser werden vielen Dank für diese
Einordnung
2022 war ein außergewöhnliches
Wetterjahr das ist die vorläufige
Jahresbilanz des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes die Sonne schien im
bundesweiten Mittel rund 2025 Stunden
solange wie nie zuvor seit Beginn der
Aufzeichnungen außerdem war das ja sehr
trocken und deutlich zu warm mit einem
Jahresmittel Temperatur von 10,5 Grad
war 2022 neben dem bisherigen Rekordjahr
2018 eines der zwei wärmsten jemals
gemessenen Jahre und könnte sogar noch
als das wärmste in die Bilanz eingehen
denn für den Silvestertag werden milde
Temperaturen erwartet
der Tod von Pelé gestern war ein solches
Welt Ereignis das andere
Todesnachrichten daneben verblassten
doch es gab ja noch eine andere
prominente Person die gestern starb und
um die viele trauern Vivian Westwood
auch sie war eine Ikone ihrer Zunft und
mehr als eine modeacherin ihrer wollen
wir heute gewissermaßen nachträglich
gedenken das macht Yasin herland für uns
sie wusste selbst sehr gut wie man sich
auf dem Laufsteg bewegt konnte also die
von ihr entworfenen Kleider auch selbst
tragen und dass sie über so viele
Jahrzehnte zu den allergrößten der
Branche zählte war vielleicht ihrer ganz
eigenen Herangehensweise ans Frauen
einkleiden zu verdanken
wenn du kleiner trägst die so stark und
extrem sind wie diese sollen sie die
helfen deine Persönlichkeit
hervorzuheben es sind Kleider die dich
nicht verstecken sie unterstützen Dich
versteckt hat sie selbst sich nie die
Provokation
immer dazu gehört ein Erbe vielleicht
aus der Zeit als aus der
Grundschullehrerin die Mode Queen des
Punkte wurde als Kostüm Ausstatterin der
sexpistels und Ehefrau des Managers der
Band Marke McLaren mit dem sie Anfang
der 70er einen Klamottenladen eröffnete
der abwechselnd so aufregende Namen trug
wie let it rock oder Sex
der Weg zur topdesignerin war gleich
wohl nicht ohne Herausforderungen sei es
für Supermodel sweet no Mic Campbell
oder die Westwood selbst Gott sei Dank
half ihr eins Gottschalk wieder auf die
Plateauschuhe breit gefächert engagierte
sie sich für politische Themen sei es
den Klimaschutz Tierschutz oder die
Freilassung des Wikileaks Gründers
Julien Assange
ihr ehemaliger Schüler und Ehemann
Andreas Kronthaler in ihrem Mode
Imperium aus weil Jahrzehnten weg und
für alle Ewigkeit wird ihr Name jedoch
vor allem für eines stehen starke Mode
für starke Frauen
das ist heute die letzte heute journal
Sendung in diesem Jahr und was war das
für ein Jahr ein Satz der sich auch auf
vielen weihnachts- und Neujahrskarten
findet oft verbunden mit der Hoffnung
auf ein besseres friedlicheres neues
Jahr
hoffen darf man hoffen muss man immer
und es ist jetzt zum Glück auch so dass
nicht immer alles so schlimm kommt wie
befürchtet trotzdem werden wir hier wohl
auch weiterhin sein was wir schon in
diesem Jahr zu oft waren die Überbringer
schlechter Botschaften Botschaften die
den Rahmen des Erwerb waren bei weitem
streckten
und wir haben hier auf unseren
redaktionsfluren in diesem Jahr oft
darüber gesprochen wie unfassbar vieles
von dem ist worüber wir berichten unser
Kollege Christian von Rechenberg hat
daraus einen Film gemacht ein
Jahresrückblick der
heute-journal-redaktion
2022 wie soll man dieses Jahr fassen die
Jahre zuvor hatten es doch schon in sich
als wir das Unerhörte erlebten das
Undenkbare aber dieses Jahr dieses 22
das hatte noch mal eine ganz andere
Wucht also die Wucht in der sich
Gewissheiten auflösen die Wucht in der
man Fehleinschätzungen erkennt die Wucht
der Ereignisse wir haben manchmal das
Gefühl dieses Jahr
2022 hätten zehn heute schon ein Jahre
gepasst
das Jahr ist noch nicht alt als wir am
24 Februar Aufwachen ist die Welt eine
andere es hatte sich angekündigt es kam
von allen denkbaren Szenarien das
schlimmste
Russlands Überfall auf die Ukraine von
allen Seiten wir erleben eine
Zeitenwende ein untergegangenes
sowjet-reichwil Putin wieder herbei
Bomben auslöschen was ihm im Weg steht
wir streben eine Demilitarisierung und
eine Entnazifizierung der Ukraine an
alles Lüge Putin Ziel von Anfang an auf
wehrlose Menschen
der Tod geht um in der Ukraine
er trägt das Z als Zeichen für
spezialoperation bösartiger Zynismus
Propaganda fürs eigene Volk das an
Heldentaten glauben soll Geschosse
gutheißen gerichtet auf Zivilisten und
Reaktoren Angst als Druckmittel
für fake-verhandlungen
trotz vereinbarter Waffenruhe Treffen in
der Hafenstadt Mariupol heute Bomben
eine Entbindungsklinik schwangere Frauen
als Ziel
Butcher einst Kiews friedliche Vororte
sind Massengräber die Bevölkerung zahlt
den Preis für Russlands frühe
Misserfolge
sie gehen rein wenn ihnen ein Haus
gefällt erschießen alle sie schmeißen
die Leichen raus verbrennen sie und dann
übernachten Sie dort putin wird Soldaten
die hier mordeten später auszeichnen und
die Bilder aus Butcher als Inszenierung
verwöhnen
Reportagen aus der Apokalypse
für mich ist Butcher in diesem Krieg ein
Schlüsselmoment gewesen weil wir haben
da zum ersten Mal gesehen mit welcher
hemmungslosen aber gleichzeitig auch
systematischen Brutalität Russland Krieg
gegen die ukrainische Zivilbevölkerung
führt das war für mich ein Moment wo ich
gesehen habe das ist ein
Zivilisationsbruch der heute mitten in
Europa stattfindet
vor dem fast ein Viertel der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung flieht zu den
Grenzen nach Westen und weiter wo
überwältigende Hilfsbereitschaft wartet
Momente der Menschlichkeit so wertvoll
im Wahnsinn dieses Krieges
Zusammenhalt macht stärker dazu gehört
ein Präsident der nicht müde wird zu
seinem Volk zu sprechen eines seiner
ersten Videos mit samtkabinett wohl sein
wichtigstes wir sind alle hier das
Militär ist hier die Bürger sind hier
wir verteidigen unsere Unabhängigkeit
unser Land der Präsident omnipes jedes
Bild wohl durchdacht jedes Wort wirkt
auch im ZDF heute journal
wir brauchen von Kanzler Scholz die
Sicherheit dass Deutschland die Ukraine
unterstützt er und seine Regierung
müssen sich entscheiden soll Deutschland
schwere Waffen liefern Panzerhaubitzen
schützen Panzer bloß nicht direkt besser
im Ringtausch lange Diskussionen darüber
die 100 Milliarden für die Bundeswehr
waren rasch beschlossen hier muss warten
für alle demokratische Welt einen
Vorteil haben die Verteidiger sie sehen
im Internet wohin sie schießen müssen
private Satelliten hatten Putins
generelle wohl übersehen wer nicht
abgeschossen wird bleibt liegen
Blitzkrieg ohne Benzin
wochenlang verteidigt eine kleine Gruppe
Kämpfe erfolgreich das Stahlwerk in
mariopold die Ukraine versenkt das
Flaggschiff der russischen
Schwarzmeerflotte sprengt die
krimmbrücke erobert Gebiete zurück
was mich auch immer wieder beeindruckt
hat war dieses dieser durchhalte Wille
der durchhalte Wille der Ukraine ist
enorm und bündelt sich in einem Satz
wir lachen damit wir nicht weinen müssen
Weinen mussten wir mit Lydia aus irpin
ich weine nicht wegen diesem Desaster
ich weine wegen unserer kraftvollen und
schönen Juden
die Geld gesammelt hat
lidias Haus wieder aufbaut die
trostspendet
mit unserer Jugend muss man sich vor
nichts fürchten nicht vor Krieg oder
irgendeiner Katastrophe von nichts sie
werden alles aufräumen wieder aufbauen
und alles wird wieder schön werden und
während sie an einem Ort tapfer aufbauen
und gehen woanders wieder geschossen
nieder Zermürbungskrieg Mord mit allen
Mitteln
Energie macht der pressbar auch uns das
Land Deutschland in diesem Jahr und das
ist auch ohne Gas aus Russland geht aber
es geht nicht gut Putin dreht die
Pipeline zu wir die Heizung Stück für
Stück Gerät die Regierung unter Druck
womit sollen wir heizen wie viel ist
überhaupt noch da und wie sollen das
bezahlen
Deutschland Start auf gasfüllstände
unter Energieminister spricht Klartext
Gas ist von nun an ein knappes Gut
Geduld auch denn die ohnehin gewaltige
Belastung befeuert eine eben solche
Inflation es brodelt im Volk was tun
das ist ja ein doppelbums doppelbums 200
Milliarden der Bund zahlt mit bei Gas
und Strom vom Tankrabatt stecken sich
die Ölkonzerne ordentlich was ein und
zahlen dafür selbst einen hohen Preis
die übergewinnsteuer kommt
der Wumms weckt Begehrlichkeiten
Energiespar Lektion
wenn da jemand sagt ich helfe nur wenn
ich noch mal 50 Euro Kriege würde ich
sagen die kriegst du nicht Alter
ich finde das Land hat gut reagiert es
gab keine geldwesten Proteste und am
Ende ist auch die Regierung über ihren
eigenen Schatten gesprungen und hat
gegen ihre eigenen Vorsätze die Sie zu
Beginn des Jahres hatte gehandelt
doppelwumms unter der Ostsee beide North
Stream Pipelines durchlöchert ein
Whirlpool aus Methan der Todesstoß für
Gas aus Russland auch zeitenwände auch
in Großbritannien das Land ahnt davon
noch nichts als das erst geburtstag
feiert und dann Thronjubiläum seiner
Queen in Amt und Alter hochbetagt eine
vollendete
als die Familie zu ihr nach Schottland
eilt hält das Land den Atem an
und sie zwei Stille Diener die eine
knappe Notiz zum Zaun von Buckingham
Palace tragen die Königin ist tot
eine gigantin geht ihr Empire war schon
lange vor ihr gegangen und lebt wieder
auf im Angesicht des Todes
Glanz und Gloria
lebe wohl zu sagen tut weh und trotzdem
tut es gut überhaupt trauern zu können
viele die hier um die Queen weinten
holten auch die Trauer um ihre
corona-toten nach
mein letztes Mal ist Elisabeth II Fels
und Anker ihres Volkes
was ich beeindruckend fand war dass
viele Leute traurig waren
dass ein
Fest des Lebens der Queen das war das
Königreich das alle liebten das
Königreich der Queen und es war wie das
bessere Großbritannien das war so ein
Gefühl was ich sehr stark empfunden habe
dass sie für das Stand was die Briten
eigentlich sein wollen und jetzt nicht
mehr sind
auch im September meine Frau von vielen
in Iran voller Träume und Hoffnung in
einer Realität die das nicht vorsieht
nicht für Frauen sie leiden sie sterben
stehen der Stille folgt der Aufschrei
Folgen Hymnen der Hoffnung
für die Frau für das Leben für die
Freiheit verbrennen Irans Frauen ihr
Kopftuch riskieren ihr Leben aber sie
längst keins mehr haben weil eine von
ihnen mach so Amini die Nacht im
Polizeigewahrsam nicht überlebt
hergebracht wegen eines Kopftuchs
weggebracht im Koma
Iran brennt lichterloh
und diese Botschaft kommt an in diesen
Tagen
diese auch
sie stehen für Veränderung Courage es
beginnt etwas Großes
die Frauen die im Iran auf die Straße
gehen die haben unser aller Hochachtung
verdient und meine haben sie auf jeden
Fall ich finde das bemerkenswert ich
finde das mutig und es zeigt vor allem
wie verzweifelt diese Menschen sind
nicht nur die Frauen auch die Männer ich
glaube inzwischen haben auch die Männer
verstanden dass auch ihre Freiheit
gleichermaßen mit der Freiheit der
Frauen einhergeht und deswegen ist das
so wichtig
und deswegen haben sie einander
untergehakt der Todesstrafe und den
Mulas zum Trotz Frauen und Männer
Heldinnen und Helden auch zeitenwände
immer wenn ich mit unseren
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauern Rede kommt
eigentlich ein Satz jedes Mal nämlich
bitte bringt auch mal Nachrichten die
ein bisschen Hoffnung machen
es gab diese Nachrichten zum Glück die
Redakteurinnen und Redakteure das heute
Journals haben ein paar eingesammelt
keinesfalls abschließend und auf jeden
Fall sehr subjektiv
mein positiven Moment in diesem Jahr war
die Goldmedaille von Niklas Kaul in zehn
Kampf bei der Europameisterschaft die
Bundesregierung verdoppelt Mittel zum
Kampf gegen den Hunger das 9 € Ticket
die NASA hat es geschafft einen
Asteroiden aus der Umlaufbahn zu drängen
dass wir ein angepassten Corona
Impfstoff haben Böhmermann liegt die
nsu-akten zum Glück wurden die Affen
Brocken kein zweites Corona das kann ich
Orchester aus der Ukraine gewinnt den
Eurovision Song Contest
quantenforscher bekommen den Physik
Nobelpreis
Taylor Swift besetzt Platz 1 bis 10 der
amerikanischen Charts überall auf der
Welt stehen Menschen für ihre Rechte ein
riskieren alles kämpfen für Demokratie
und das hat viel Gutes und macht
Hoffnung für das nächste Jahr das
hoffentlich ein friedlicheres wird und
dass wir wieder sehr genau im Blick
haben werden für Sie
das tun wir und wünschen Ihnen dass Sie
gut in dieses neue Jahr kommen mögen am
2 januar sind wir dann wieder hier
zumindest darauf ist Verlass jetzt einen
angenehmen Abend ihnen und morgen einen
guten Rutsch wir sehen tschüss
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter heute
Abend Zeit für den Jahresrückblick 2022
es war 15 Prozent trockener als im
Mittel der letzten 30 Jahren mit plus
1,2 Grad bei den Temperaturen wird 2022
neben 2018 das wärmste Jahr und mit
einem außergewöhnlichen Plus von 21%
beim Sonnenschein auch das sonnigste
seit Messbeginn werden und zu warm für
diese Jahreszeit geht es jetzt auch
weiter ein Tief zapft die milde Luft aus
dem Südwesten an und so sinken die
Temperaturen heute Nacht schon nicht
unter 4 Grad im Westen bleibt es häufig
zweistellig dazu ist es aber regnerisch
und teilweise stürmisch und so geht das
auch morgen an Silvestertag weiter im
Norden sind bisschen tiefe Lagen
stürmische Böden möglich auf den Bergen
sogar Orkanböen und es regnet hier vor
allem im Nordwesten auch kräftig von
Süden her trocknet es im Tagesverlauf
aber ab und an den Alpen und im
Südwesten schaut doch häufig die Sonne
hervor und diese Sonne vor aber diese
Südwestströmung sorgt morgen für
Rekordtemperaturen mit verbreitet
zwischen 18 und 21 Grad wird der
Silvester Tag noch nie so warm gewesen
sein in Deutschland und sogar unter den
Wolken und dem Regen im Norden erreichen
wir 11 Grad also ernsthaft frieren muss
in der Silvesternacht keiner sogar um
Mitternacht erreichen wir noch 9 bis 15
Grad dazu eben im Norden der Regen und
der Wind im Süden windstill und trocken
und auch das neue Jahr geht erst einmal
zu mild und unbeständig weiter bevor es
dann am Dienstag etwas kühler wird
tschüss